während andere regierungschefs nach kiew
reisen fährt kanzler scholz nach
düsseldorf denn es herrschte wahlkampf
in nrw und so sprach scholz passend zum
ersten mal vor gewerkschaften immerhin
erfahren
mit humanitärer hilfe
[Applaus]
mit 100 ehre
weil ich der ganzen route und von
kanzler scholz doch immer gleich nochmal
genauer reinhören aber wir sprechen erst
mal mit politik chef jan schäfer denn ja
es hat sich schon so ein bisschen
angedeutet kämpferisch war er unser
kanzler und zwar so kämpferisch wie ich
persönlich bin ehrlich gesagt zuvor noch
nicht gesehen habe du nein auch noch
nicht aber das lag natürlich daran dass
es sich so ganz ruhig war dort wo er
gesprochen hat sondern wir haben es im
beitrag ja gerade eben auch ein bisschen
schon gehört da wurde kräftig im krawall
gemacht da gab es viele sirenen da gab
es auch kriegstreiber rufe also es gab
viel protest und das haben wir auf allen
mai kundgebungen in den vergangenen
tagen gesehen nicht nur gestern auch am
samstag gab es ein buttersäure anschlag
dort wo eigentlich annalena baerbock
hätte sprechen sollte sich deutschland
also da ist jetzt doch eine gewisse
unzufriedenheit bei vielen vielen
spürbar das feuer
wir wollen jetzt noch mal reinhören was
olaf scholz genau gesagt hat
wir werden die ukraine weiter
unterstützen mit geld
mit humanitärer hilfe aber auch das muss
gesagt werden wir werden sie
unterstützen dass sie sich verteidigen
kann mit waffenlieferung die viele
andere länder immer ob das aber ist es
notwendig ich wüsste gegen pazifismus
ich respektiere jede haltung aber es
muss einen bürger der ukraine schulde
spucken wie gesagt wird er solle sich
die polizeiaktion ohne waffen
verteidigen was ist aus der zeit
gewöhnen
klare worte also von olaf scholz in
letzten wochen stand er immer wieder in
der kritik seine ukraine politik zu
zögerlich zu ängstlich kann man das
jetzt als wendepunkt bezeichnet nein das
war einfach überfällig und olaf scholz
hat einfach deutliche worte gefunden und
hat gegen jene muss man ja auch sagen
angebrüllt die völlig anderer meinung
gewesen sind als er nein olaf scholz hat
in den vergangenen wochen einfach viel
zu zögerlich agiert ich glaube auch
nicht dass das jetzt ein wendepunkt ist
er sitzt das muss man sagen zwischen
ganz ganz vielen stühlen und ist nicht
in der lage kräftig jetzt den takt
vorzugeben und zu führen er wird
getrieben vom ausland gerade von
osteuropa aber auch von amerika wird
getrieben von seinen koalitionspartnern
fdp und grüne und gleichzeitig hat er
eine basis hat man hier eher zum teil in
dem beitrag jetzt auch gesehen da war
natürlich auch gewerkschafter und spd
mitglieder die seinen kurs überhaupt
nicht gut findet in der fraktion in der
eigenen fraktion viele viele bremsen
einen
bundespräsidenten der
ausgeladen wurde von der ukraine der
über 20 jahre das muss man so sagen mit
dem größten kriegstreiber dieses
jahrhunderts mit wladimir putin
gekoppelt hat in dieser gemengelage
finden sich olaf scholz und er hat es
bisher nicht geschafft hier klar führung
zu übernehmen du sagst ja wird getrieben
ein bisschen druck kommt jetzt auch von
seiten der union von der cdu friedrich
merz möchte jetzt nach kiel fahren trotz
großer sicherheitsbedenken
das erhöht den druck jetzt nochmal auf
die spd saskia esken hat jetzt gestern
gesagt na ja das könnte ja auch einfach
nur eine pr veranstaltung seien für
herrn merz das würde der ukraine jetzt
nicht viel bringen geschätzt wird ein
also auch gerade nach der rede die wir
gesehen haben wenn es so läuft falls
wirklich ernst meint mit der
unterstützung der ukraine ist ja eine
reise nach kiew eigentlich mehr oder
weniger überfällig und auch hier geht es
bei olaf scholz jetzt eigentlich und da
hatte mal wieder viel zu lange gewartet
um einen das auslösen einer lose lose
situation also verlieren und verlieren
denn würde er jetzt fahren dann hätte er
sich erkennbar dem druck gebeugt der
öffentlichkeit dass viele in der
öffentlichkeit vieler politiker auch der
beiden koalitionspartner und wäre quasi
von dem oppositionsführer friedrich merz
vorgeführt und dazu in gewisser weise
hin geboxt worden zu fahren fährt er
nicht gilt er weiterhin als total
sturköpfe ich als halsstarrig und als
verbohrt der sein als jemand der sich in
sein schneckenhaus im kanzleramt zurück
zieht also olaf scholz hat es geschafft
sich in eine situation selbst zu
manövrieren aus der eigentlich nur als
verlierer herauskommen kann was meinst
du wird er noch nach kiew reisen
es wird aber schlau gewesen von olaf
scholz vor einigen wochen schon zu sagen
ich reise nach kiew wenn die zeit dafür
richtig ist oder wenn es wenn es eine
gute möglichkeit dafür gibt da hätte er
zumindest das fenster offen gelassen
indem er reisen kann aber hätte gesagt
ich will ja reisen aber es gibt
abstimmungen und deswegen kann ich nicht
jetzt hat er bisher immer gesagt ich
reise nicht und das klingt auch ein
bisschen wie ein wirklich stuhr köpfiges
kind das sagt ich will aber nicht ich
will aber nicht ich will aber nicht und
ich glaube das ist für einen
bundeskanzler nicht die richtige art und
weise dieses land so für einen konflikt
jan schäfer dankeschön für deine
einschätzung und wenn man jetzt noch mal
gemeinsam auf unsere sendungen gestern
schauen